what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so normally on Sundays we cover
Green Lantern and the x-men but we're
not doing that today because this video
is gonna be better so a lot of you guys
really seem to enjoy the whole like
these discussions about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe right like a lot of
you guys really seem to enjoy like these
these videos on like like the Fantastic
Four in the MCU or like god help us
sony in the MCU this whole thing about
like how you would roll in the x-men and
all that kind of get stuff and you know
in this video I wanted to talk about
Wolverine for a second right I mean we
covered this to a degree and like how we
would roll the x-men over into the MCU
but for me like I think we can all
pretty much agree that like when the
x-men are announced like when cuz Marvel
will announce it when they come out and
they have that huge press conference you
know like they did with the phase 3
thing and the crowd was screaming it
everybody was going nuts when they were
announced in the movies and I watched
that video at least once a week cuz it's
like the coolest video ever I get so
hyped watching that like I get so
excited watching that like when they
make that announcement I'm people are
gonna be like alright cool yeah yeah
like the x-men but like what about
Wolverine though like that's gonna be
the only thing anybody cares about it's
gonna be the only thing they want to
talk about they're gonna be like okay
it's like who's playing him
and it's a Hugh Jackman if it's not Hugh
Jackman then why like like we need to
have a conversation about that like Hugh
Jackman needs to come back cuz I'll be
honest with the guys man like I let me
tell you I'll be honest with you guess
there would be nothing I would love more
than to see like Hugh Jackman fighting
alongside like Tony Stark or Hugh
Jackman fighting against Tony Stark
or like Captain America do they be the
coolest thing oh my god to be the
coolest thing ever
all right I'm dude I'm getting slammed
and so high just think about that but
here's the question here's like the
million dollar question let's say like
Wolverine gets rolled in DMC right like
what you will and and let's say like you
know Hugh Jackman comes back Marvel is
not gonna continue what Fox did right
mostly because Fox only had like two
good movies with Wolverine and the x-men
the first was Days of Future past and
the second was like Logan and then
everything else was just movies that
were made that feature the x-men like
their movies that exist and so I'm
sitting there thinking and I'm like you
know when they when they announced this
whole thing how do they do his origin
story what's the origin story of
Wolverine in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the more I thought about
this the more I thought back to the
video that we did on the exponent like
rollin me you know rolling the x-men
over and so on and so forth
and I started thinking about like the
nature of Wolverine now here's a cool
thing and my mind you know to kind of
modify that theory to a degree we can
basic
grab like the origin of Wolverine and we
can stem it all the way back to like
Hydra or shield I mean you get tied in
you know like like you would say like
here's here's what he popped his claws
for the first time and yadda yadda yadda
you know here's what he did all that
stuff but like the stuff that people
care about is like the crossover right
like no one wants to see a Wolverine
movie and the Marvel Cinematic Universe
that doesn't feature anybody else I
don't want to see that the cool thing
would be like the montage part right
like where we jumped through is history
kind of like they did in the Wolverine
movie except this one won't suck and
like the whole thing is it'll be like
when he was in World War two and like
fought alongside Captain America but
it'd be kind of cool to see that from
his perspective or like they reference
Captain America or something like that
because in the comics he fought
alongside Captain America for a little
while it'd be cool to have that and like
you literally just kind of jump through
that the big question that people want
to know and and here's the big thing
that people want to see how does
Wolverine get his adamantium because at
the end of the day that's the only thing
anybody ever really cares about here's
what I would say all right here he would
be my my origin for Wolverine if we had
to like walk away from introducing the
exponent of the MCU if we had to walk
away from that video and we had to give
us like a different origin for Wolverine
here would be my idea in terms of how he
got his adamantium I would take it all
the way back and basically say like
Howard Stark and like like Peggy Carter
and all those guys are the ones
responsible for Wolverine getting is
adamantium and here's the reason why so
basically the whole thing stems back to
Captain America right like you know
project rebirth Steve Rogers is like
gosh golly I'm just a weak guy but I
really want to fight the war that cost
millions of lives because what could go
wrong and so like he shows up he's like
I really want to fight in the world war
two he's like I don't like bullies even
though you know I'm kind of a dick in
the comics a little bit sometimes so so
like he goes to him and and he becomes
Captain America like they basically
inject him with steroids blast him with
some rays and then he becomes Captain
America that was from the honest
trailers video actually it was hilarious
is like like a weak guy named Steve
Rogers becomes Captain America and the
most American way possible steroids like
it was hilarious
anyway so Steve Rogers becomes Captain
America all right and then like Abraham
Erskine dies so Abraham Erskine is gone
all right so there's no more Super
Soldier Serum hence the whole basis
behind the significance of Captain
America is there will never be another
version of him now what we do is instead
of doing like a Marvel Comics where you
had basically like like the CIA and
Canada's Department H or Department K or
whatever it was working in like a joint
venture to create Weapon X and then it
or I guess weapons Plus and in the turn
go through all IKEA instead of doing all
that stuff instead like we would
title on the shield they would say like
okay so Captain America was believed to
have been dead
and once Peggy Carter stopped crying you
know and when she finally got it all
together and she was like okay we need
to find a way to either make a new
Captain America
I'm sorry finding to find this Captain
America or make a new Captain America
but the fact that was believed that he
was dead so the only alternative was to
make a new one and so what they did is
they basically launched weapons Plus
under the banner of the SSR the
strategic science reserve now the whole
thing behind this is like Hydra was
operating behind the scenes and Hydra
knew about it because they were kind of
controlling shield from the inside
because arms all I was living in a
computer and nobody ever suspected
computers of evil and so because of that
like they were just kind of there in the
background and they were just like okay
you know we're watching all this unfold
but Hydra chose not to do anything about
it because Hydra could basically just
co-opt the project and then turn it into
their own personal super soldier if it
worked and so under the banner of the
SSR what you had is you have like weapon
one and I'm sorry weapon two and three
and four and five yadda yadda yadda so
on and so forth and all that basically
runs up to Weapon X now we can tie Hydra
into it because shortly after world war
two was over going into the Cold War
like Howard Stark was killed by the
Winter Soldier basically Hydra
orchestrated the assassination of Howard
Howard a Maria Stark and the Marvel
Cinematic Universe by using Bucky Barnes
as the Winter Soldier so nobody would
trace it back to Hydra inside of shield
and so because of that Peggy Carter
eventually retires Chester Phillips
Tommy Lee Jones essentially I guess he
dies I don't remember what ever happened
in I mean I know he dies like he doesn't
he's not gonna live forever he's not
Nick Fury from the comics so like he
dies retires whatever and so hydras
basically running the show and where the
strategic scientific reserve has a whole
project going once the SSR transition
and became shield their projects
continued on and the project's kept
going just like they always did now one
of the ways this is one of the things
that people will ask they'll say well
how can we never heard about it before
why wasn't it ever referenced before
well the answer to that question comes
out of Captain America the Winter
Soldier when we have like the whole
discussion between Steve Rogers and and
Nick Fury when we end up finding out
that Nick Fury had sent Black Widow
alongside Steve Rogers at the beginning
of the movie where we had that amazing
fight between Captain America and Batroc
the leaper and like Black Widow was
there to like gain information on Hydra
but like Captain America wasn't notified
about it and when he asked Nick Fury why
Nick Fury said well I'm
compartmentalizing we can literally
throw that in there and just say it's
one of like the zillions of projects
Nick Fury had under his belt that nobody
knew about and when shield came crashing
down but it somehow managed to survive
an eight missile shield even though
nobody
seems to know what's going on it's by
the fact like the world gets blown in
half and like there's an international
manhunt for all the members of shield
yet somehow the Avengers and Captain
America don't know they're like the most
oblivious superheroes ever like gee I
wonder what's in the newspaper today oh
nothing let's just turn the page and go
to the next thing no way this is shield
in every newspaper talking about a man
on this is why the movies are the TV
army to line up because right now you
just you're running into the comic book
continuity equivalent of like the movies
is basically we're running into
continuity errors but nonetheless like
like you could literally say like it's
one of the zillions of projects that he
had going on behind the scenes and
nobody ever knew about it nobody was
aware of what it was going on even will
rein himself didn't know what it was and
then events that we end up having things
that come out of that but you did do all
that kind of stuff like in jessica jones
you had Frank Simpson basically nuke you
could say like he was part of the
weapons Plus program in the later days
of it maybe you're some along those
lines I don't quite know how you would
make that work because Frank Simpson is
really really new whereas Wolverine
would have to be old it would have to be
a project either done in like the 70s to
80s to the 90s I mean you could go with
like the Ultimate Universe origin of
Wolverine but I don't think that was as
cool as my idea I like my idea better so
I feel like we should go with that
because you know like I didn't make this
video for no reason Marvel so light so I
that's that's my whole philosophy on
this thing I think you should be tied
into shield because what it does is a
Tate shield away from being just like
this gosh golly really good organization
that only does great things because you
know Peggy Carter and Howard Stark
formed it and it turns into like this
kind of nefarious organization were
basically the whole weapons Plus project
amounted to like human experimentation
some of it was like sanctioned but like
some of it wasn't like you know
Wolverine and and like Sabretooth and
whoever else you know maverick and and
Silver Fox they were all part of like
the original team X they were basically
part of like the whole you know blackops
wet work team working for the CIA and
like the like she'll just showed up and
took him and just like threw him into
the project and was like okay cool like
adamantium everybody gets it now oh my
god Wolverine broke out like like that'd
be the hole that'd be the cool thing
that would go on there a lot of it was
like swept under the rug maybe it was
ignored maybe this is something that
that Tony Stark learns from his father
Howard Stark and that leads into the
whole thing of wool right I don't know
there's a zillion ways that you could do
it but I feel like it should be stemmed
from a shield like shield were the ones
a creative Wolverine shield were the
ones that like create a Deadpool
inadvertently like like
indirectly you know there's there's a
zillion things you could do with that um
I'm curious to see what they do
I mean from what I understand we're a
few years out but still like I think
that Wolverine is gonna be the most
anticipated character in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe once like the x-men
are officially rolled in because I don't
know anybody who doesn't believe the Fox
20 deal is gonna go through or the Fox
Disney deal is gonna go through I mean
it's Disney for Christ sakes man these
those those folks are magic they can
make anything happen
so like I'm pretty sure it'll go through
and when it does like Wolverine will be
the move that's that's the only thing
anybody I mean they're gonna be
interested in the x-men Fantastic Four
so on and so forth but none of the news
about those groups will be as huge as
the news about Wolverine cuz people are
gonna want to know who's gonna cast him
they're gonna want to know like what the
movies gonna be about I mean I would say
if I'm gonna be if I'm gonna be honest I
would say that the Wolverine movie when
it comes out like if it's the solo film
when it comes out it'll have outsold
everything it'll outdo black panther it
might outdo the Avengers I'm not sure
and it'll certainly outsell all the
other movies because it'll be the first
time that we see someone presumably
that's not Hugh Jackman playing the role
of Wolverine in 17 years and it's not
run by Fox
it's run by Marvel their first outing
with Wolverine everybody's gonna want to
know what's up because you know it's
Wolverine he's the best is it what he
does you know and then what he does is
is get rebooted all the time without
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
come as explained make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb for if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop on like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you